I'm Gregory Hirsch.
Well, I'm not Gregory now.
My human name is Nicholas Braun
and I play Gregory Hirsch
in Succession.
And my human name is
Matthew Macfadyen.
My make-believe human name
is Tom Wambsgans.
And we're about to play
a game called "Who Said It?"
I'm not gonna put a voice
on it or any--
No, just do it straight.
-Just the words and then--
-Yeah.
And I'm terrible
at things like this anyways.
It's time to play the game.
(CHUCKLES)
Then, let us begin.
Let us begin.
"He made me a fucking offer
and I'm going to redeem
that coupon."
I think it's Shiv.
You're right.
I won't give up. I won't.
He made me a fucking offer
and I'm going to redeem
that coupon.
Season two, episode eight.
Said to you,
re: Logan's offer
to have her take over.
Yeah, that's why I remembered
it 'cause it was-- yeah.
-BRAUN: It was said to you.
-MACFADYEN: It was said to me.
I memorize all your scenes.
-Do you?
-Even if I'm not in them.
I watch the dailies.
Are you involved in the editing
of the show?
-Yes, weirdly all your scenes.
-I didn't know that. Okay.
They let me pop in there
and chop, chop, chop.
Did they ask you if you wanted
to be involved or did you--
They actually asked me if I
wanted to direct your scenes.
-Really? Really?
-Yeah. But I'm not... yeah.
Okay, on we go.
Come on, Nick. Do well.
Go on, give it your best shot.
"Sometimes, it is--"
a big dick competition.
Logan.
-Yes!
-Yes.
Good scene. Great scene.
Okay, who says this?
"I didn't want you to find out
this way, Tom,
but I'm in a sexual relationship
with your mother."
Oh, that's Roman.
Wrong. It's Gerri.
It's tough to have to tell you
like this,
but I'm in a sexual relationship
with your mother.
She talks in her sleep.
That's a very sharp Gerri line.
It is. She's sort of putting me
back in my box,
'cause I'm threatening to have
a press conference
about the cruise line stuff.
-Tom!
-Yes?
Sit on the floor!
It's fun.
-Seriously?
-Yeah, it's a game.
"Boar on the Floor."
-TOM WAMBSGANS:
I really... I feel...
-Get down!
"I wanna see
you piggy fucks eat."
Oh, that's Logan
in "Boar on the Floor."
-BRAUN: It's Roman
on "Boar on the Floor."
-MACFADYEN: What?!
BRAUN: Yeah.
MACFADYEN:
Joining in like daddy.
The next one is,
"The Logan Roy
School of Journalism.
What's next? The Jack the Ripper
Women's Health Clinic?"
MACFADYEN: I think it's Gerri.
I think it's Karl.
Name a few more characters.
I think it's Roman, actually.
Or Shiv.
-Who's my grandpa?
-James Cromwell.
The Logan Roy
School of Journalism.
What's next? The Jack the Ripper
Women's Health Clinic?
Here comes the next one at ya.
"Welcome to our city
on the water.
It's like Venice,
but it smells nice."
Uh, let's see if I can do
an impression.
Welcome to our--
No, that's not good.
-(LAUGHS)
-That's not good.
Welcome to our city
on the water.
It's like Venice,
but it smells nice.
-Thank you very much.
Looks delicious.
-Thank you.
BRAUN: Connor.
I was trying to do Connor.
Okay, "Go hard, go fast,
you lovely bastards."
(LAUGHS)
What could that be about?
Oh, oh, oh!
-Roman. Soccer team.
-Yes! Yes!
Perfect.
ROMAN ROY: Go hard, go fast.
Go, you lovely bastards.
Go, you lovely bastards?
What the fuck
am I supposed to say?
I have no idea.
I don't know how I dug that out.
Nick won.
I think it was fair.
(LAUGHS)
♪ (INTENSE MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
KENDALL ROY: I'm a good guy.
I'm better than you.
We'll fucking beast them.
(GROANING)
We'll go full fucking beast!